[Music]
you've been on the show many times one
of the times are on the show and we've
talked about it on several different
appearances you mentioned that you like
to go to Korean spas I did they offered
we were gonna have a day you offered to
go to a Korean spa with me and we never
made that happen are we gonna make it
happen is this the offer back he
responding three years later and saying
let's do this well I got bad news for
you which is I went to a Korean spa with
another man I'm sorry Steven Yeun from
walking dead he mentioned it to me and
he goes all the time and he said why
don't you not trying to be racist and I
don't know if he owned as a Korean name
but is you own a Korean name because if
the gentleman is Korean I'm okay with
that but if he's not Korean I have a
yeah yeah yeah excuse my language eyes
open he's hurt he's Swiss no I he is he
is no french-kissing yeah yeah yeah
Seana he is Korean he is Korean and so I
went with him and so it was you know
important to me to have a cultural
ambassador yeah two Irishmen felt
redundant sorry as they so often do is
they so often do and so I go and I had
no idea it was nude
you're completely nude the entire time
is that what who I wanted to bring you
yeah
because I have it twisted but fully
heterosexual fascination with the large
members of our male society and the
smaller members of our male society and
how they may be generally represented
right right wanted to I wanted to I
wanted to have a look at your gear man
yeah no we can address that anytime
that's the time that you move in for the
touch I want to see your gear man moving
I could just go back and get my cell
phone well first of all we have a
picture here I felt awkward the entire
time I am so white so pale and what you
didn't tell me is that they beat the
crap out of you there's a kind of oh
yeah
a man a Korean man kind of a man no he
he was laughing maniacally and and and
scrubbing me and it hurt more than
anything I've experienced in my life yet
and when he was done I was red red as a
lobster no connection to the movie
coming to a cinema
coming soon to a cinema near you near
you might have to drive a bit no no it's
coming to you and scrape my skin off
have you done that I have I have not had
somebody scrape my skin off but yeah
I've taken a couple of licks couple of
meetings yeah yeah I remember one time
when I went in one day to there's a
Russian Turkish bathhouse in New York
that's really brilliant and I went in
one day and I was feeling this is years
ago I was feeling really low and myself
and so I got two guys to give me the
platter and I just kept asking them
harder harder and they beat Jesus out of
me what is that what is that they asked
me to put a shirt on before I went
upstairs because they thought the
manager if the manager saw the welts on
my body that they'd be fired
what were they beating you with yeah oak
leaves oh they look like a cheerleader
pom-poms and some twisted kind of grim
fairy tale yeah yeah it's Oh Cleves I'm
becoming aroused by this whole
again my intention completely yeah yeah
we thought what it was and did you say
he beat you with a stick no no he had
like I think he had like a salt scrub so
oh that's horrible if you have never had
those but I remember I remember seeing
you on video getting it yeah yeah yeah
is it in house I can I get it online
[Laughter]
wait no saw I wouldn't have brought you
to a salt scrub you backed the wrong
pony man with mr. Ewing yeah you should
have come with me
I'm with his pom-poms all over you oh
well maybe we'll go to a different spot
with you and you can check out my gear
yeah hey cool it sounds like a day you
heard it here first
yeah any really yeah yeah I'll have a
little surgery first
you